[Music]
in science in the soul I have a chapter
on reasonable doubt and it's about of
course the phrase reasonable doubt comes
up in courts of law where juries are
told that they must convict somebody say
of murder only if there is it's beyond
reasonable doubt that they are guilty
and that sounds all very good it should
be beyond reasonable doubt but when you
think about the fact that I'd think
about courtroom dramas which is so
popular on television for example and I
and I suspect that this accurately
portrays something like what goes on in
real courtrooms and I've certainly been
on three juries myself there is a note
of suspense in the court when the jury
comes back which way will they go will
it be guilty or not guilty
and then if they say not guilty certain
people heave a great sigh of relief if
they say guilty other people do so there
is a lot of doubt in the courtroom among
people who've sat through the entire
trial the judge for example the lawyers
the audience sat through the entire
trial as the jury has so if the jury
comes in and brings in a verdict that is
beyond reasonable doubt everybody in the
court should know that if it's beyond
reasonable doubt there can be no doubt
of which way the jury will will jump and
yet when the jury do give their verdict
you go ahh how can that be if it's
beyond reasonable doubt imagine the
following experiment suppose that you
had two juries listening to the same
evidence and the two juries not allowed
to talk to each other they're sent off
into separate jury rooms and they come
up with their own separate verdicts who
would bet on the jury's coming back with
the same verdict every single time
virtually nobody would in my if you
think about the OJ Simpson trial for
example with anything for Tibet or
another jury coming up with the same
verdict and yet unless you can bet
unless you can say yes they would come
up with the same verdict you cannot
really take the phrase beyond reasonable
doubt seriously now I'm not suggesting
that we should have two juries in
trial I'm just pointing out that the
phrase beyond reasonable doubt doesn't
actually mean what it says
[Music]